Okay, it came in the bag which was
knotted like six times. It was in a bag
that had six knots.
Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have.
Case closed. Allah tells us that a man
when he is soul is taken away, Allah
says he's going to say what? Send me
back to do Hajj, Umrah, Salah, fasting?
What? No. Sadaqah. Brothers and sisters,
IERA is getting thousands of Shahadas
monthly, yearly, hundreds of thousands
of people are coming to Islam. They are
printing Quran, distributing material,
training dot. Brothers and sisters, do
you want a part of that Sadaqah Jariyah
that goes on forever? This is how Islam
has spread around the world, brothers
and sisters. Carry on this legacy of the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
inshallah by donating whatever amount
inshallah and support IERA right now
inshallah. Enjoy the video.
Assalamualaikum Warahmatullahi
Wabarakatuh, brothers and sisters and
dear friends. Hope you guys are well
inshallah. This is a video that I saw
Subhanallah of these two, I think they
might be non-Muslim girls who have find
something in in I think they do like
magnetic, they have these magnetic
things they throw in the lake or river
or wherever and they get all the stuff.
Subhanallah, look how evil people are.
And this is why you know Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala, the Quran is the Haq. You
know why? Because people
look, there are those who want other
people who are married. Yes? Okay. So,
they themselves may be single and they
want to that person to marry them and
they want to cause divorce. Or there are
people who are just in misery for
whatever reason, life decisions that
they made. They ended up divorced or
whatever the matter and they have hatred
towards someone else. Now, there are two
kinds of jealousy. Jealousy one which is
permissible you see someone who's
happily married and you're like, "Oh
Allah, bless them, protect them. Give me
the same."
Evil kind of jealousy which a lot of
these nifaqi feminists have on TikTok,
absolute reckless
nutters, absolute nutters. Um
who try to destroy other people's
marriages. That is another extreme which
you are sinful for, okay? Recklessly
asking women to divorce etc. You are
Iblis.
Let me tell you something. You are Iblis
if you are actively trying to destroy
the people's marriages, okay? So, let's
watch this video, inshallah, and see for
yourself. Look what they discover, and
we're going to watch videos on telling
you how you can get rid of this and
protect you against sayer and magic.
Okay. It came in the bag, which was
knotted like six times. Okay,
interesting. There you go. It was in a
bag that had six knots.
What does Allah say in the Quran when it
comes to knots? Yes?
And then, the ayah, this verse was sent
to Muhammad the Prophet, sala Allahu
alayhi wasallam,
was affected by sayer, subhana Allah,
and it's an example to us to show that
we do not make the Prophet, sala Allahu
alayhi
something greater than he was. Yes,
which he was a mighty, mighty, amazing
prophet, but we don't go to levels of he
is the noor of Allah and all all this
kind of stuff, subhana Allah. Yes, okay.
We don't go to extremes in our faith.
Yes?
And then, we know Qul Huwa Allahu Ahad,
Allahu Samad, Lam Yalid Wa Lam Yulad, Wa
Lam Yakun Lahu Kufuwan Ahad. So, that
was sent to the Prophet, sala Allahu
alayhi wasallam, because there was the
amount of knots that were done, I think
it was 12 or 13. But, let's carry on.
And then, it has
writing. So, just looking at the
writing, there's something written
there. We don't know what's written
there, but something is written there.
And this is part of the magic. Yes? It's
part of the spell.
It was taped shut.
Um
you open it up, and there's
this girl, and then part of a dollar
bill, and then this has
the same girl on it.
Um and then, we were like, "Oh, there's
needles."
>> Okay, you can see the dollar bill, cuz
dollar bill has got the Illuminati sign,
subhana Allah. There's probably
connections. And then, there's images of
a girl, they use character like cartoon
uh subhanallah for God knows what reason
subhanallah but yeah. How weird.
It's through their eyes. Through their
eyes and her crotch and her forehead.
So, you can see here they laugh
obviously they don't know they just like
okay what is this? This is seher. This
is actually look at it. Look at the
staples on the eyes of the guy,
the forehead of the woman, her eyes,
and his um private areas. Well, towards
his thighs, yes? Okay. So,
this can be seher done so he does not
have children.
Uh this can be seher done to harm them.
Uh their eyes or it can be seher that
they are blinded to one another. Not
literal blindness but you know um they
don't see the goodness. Do you get it?
So, when you're talking about see it's
not visual see, okay? It's the heart see
as well. So, it's a not seeing good. So,
when you see couples fighting I'm not
saying all the time it's that. Please
guys don't go to this other extreme of
you know we have arguments etc. I was
seher black magic someone did this to
me. People like it can be but there's
ways of protecting yourself which I'm
going to come to. But you can see the
eyes can symbolize that he doesn't see
good in her.
Or she doesn't see good in him, okay?
And this is very important because you
don't want to be affected by magic or
seher or whatever for that matter.
Gratitude is very important between
couples. It's very important. And Allah
says in the Quran if you are grateful I
will increase you. Increase you in what?
Allah doesn't say you. Maybe increase
you in more gratitude. If you
and this is very important and advice I
give to both couples both men and women
to be grateful to one another. Okay, yes
we know the hadith of the Prophet
Muhammad that women are more inclined to
be ungrateful towards their husbands and
the Prophet Muhammad saw the majority of
the inhabitants of the hellfire
ungrateful women, okay? So, the majority
of the inhabitants are sober women and
they were ungrateful. He told them and
he gave them a cure. He said sadaqa do
more sadaqa and some of them didn't come
and had a fit like these munafiqis on
TikTok. How dare I don't like that
I don't like the it's like me reading a
verse in the Quran and it says if men
turn their back on in war
it's major sin it's hellfire. And I'm
like, "Yo, I'm in war. Like, people are
shooting. Of course, I have to Unless
it's like strategic, yeah? But of
course, there might be moments where I'm
going to retreat, etc." I'm not going to
be like, "Nah, I don't like that. I
don't Allah,
I don't like that. I'm so sorry." The
mission of Allah, "Nah, sorry. My Like,
you know Allah says in Quran, have you
seen those who may Subhan Allah take
parts of the kitab and parts of I like
this, I don't like that. Eat up. Nah.
This one, nah. No. We are consistent
because if there's things that stimulate
us, which there are many as men, we have
to do We don't complain. We don't
complain. We say, "Did Allah and his
messenger say that?" That's what Allah
says in the Quran. When Allah and his
messenger say something, it is nothing
else befitting for the believer except
that they say, "We heard and we obey."
That is iman. Not like these nifaqis and
these red pillars. They don't really see
this with with all due respect. Men
don't come and complain about their
duties, yes? Okay. So, this is very
important for us to submit and
understand that Subhan Allah. Gratitude,
guys, okay? See now, this can be that
And there are those who don't have sihr,
and they're ungrateful to their wife.
And they're ungrateful to their husband,
yes? Something small happens. Oh, like
that's what the Prophet said. He's good,
good, good, good, good, good, good. He
does one thing, "I've never seen any
good from him." This is the pinnacle of
ingratitude. And if men do the same as
well, you got a good wife, etc. She's
good, she's that, etc. And you nitpick,
yeah? "Oh, the food was salty." Shut up,
bro. Shut up. Have some salt in your
body, okay? You probably got less salt
in your body. Maybe you need salt in
your body. Yes, okay. Subhan Allah. "Oh,
she doesn't She didn't do that." No.
Don't be like that. So, don't be people
who Look, these couple maybe they love
each other so much that they have to do
sihr. Don't be among those that destroy
their own marriage with ingratitude. Be
thankful to one another. Alhamdulillah
is a word that it used to Subhan Allah,
but let's carry on what happens with
this.
Um
Oh, Subhan Allah. Yeah, there you go. I
mean, the thing with the the mind might
be that the woman's mind is going to be
quite fragile and she can be easily
influenced. Maybe they're trying to do
that to disrupt it, etc. So, I don't
know. Like, they're they're trying to
attack this
this couple in any way, shape or form.
So, now if we go to the comment section,
let's see what the comments were saying.
So, the comment section have this,
"Please take it to your mosque in your
local area and they will Sorry. And they
will destroy it properly so that the
spell is removed. It's very dangerous.
Girl, that's a spell. I claim no
negative energy from this video." Well,
that's not going to help you. Just
saying I claim I in the name Please.
Okay.
It's a We'll do etc. And you can see the
comment section etc. Okay. So, now what
is the solution? So, we're going to go
to a video of Sheikh Assim al-Hakeem and
another
Sheikh inshallah, Dr. Muhammad al-Salah.
Guy from Bangladesh,
a man gave him something to hang on the
wall to prevent evil eye or black magic
etc. So, it's a sort of a
ta'wiz
in in in large size. So, he did this and
then he figured out that this is haram,
so he threw it from the window.
Did he do the right thing? The answer is
no.
He should have burnt it
with fire
while reciting the last three Qul. Qul
Huwa Allahu Ahad, Qul A'udhu bi Rabbil
Falaq, Qul A'udhu bi Rabbil Nas.
But, as he disposed of it without uh
doing this, I I hope there's nothing
wrong in that inshallah.
>> still have that bag with the shreds and
the pieces of the animal?
>> I
No, I threw it in the dustbin. Okay.
Well,
um obviously this is some sort of
either an amulet or a magical spell.
And in this case, the best way to
dispose it is
via burning it.
So, you should have
either
asked before you shredded and you threw
it away.
Or if you still have an access to it, it
should be burnt.
And I do not necessarily link between
this amulet or the magical spell,
which most likely is a magical spell,
and the diseases which you encounter.
Um so, what I would advise you if you
alhamdulillah you're following up and
doing your regular checkup with the
doctor, taking your proper treatment
clinically,
and meanwhile reciting your al quran and
reciting surat al baqarah at least in 10
day
once every day for about 10 days or so
in order to ward off any effect of any
magical spell and to keep it off your
house and your household.
May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala keep you
safe and protect you. So, there you go.
You worship for yourself, brothers and
sisters. Look,
it is critical and key for you to do
your morning and evening al quran. Look,
I'm in the public sphere. I don't mess
around with this, bro. Black magic, evil
eye, I've got enemies. And most of them
are Muslims. Yeah, Saudi, not Zionist,
not Christian, not Hindu. Fear those,
okay. I've got I've got Muslims who try
to harm me, okay. So,
your salah has to be on point.
Major sins, bye-bye. You got to say
bye-bye to them. Sadaqah, we've got a
link there for sadaqah. Sadaqah, the
prophet said, will get in the way of
calamity. Calamity way, look, this could
be heading towards them. Sadaqah is in
the way. Cure your sick with sadaqah.
Sadaqah will never make you poor. Uh
protect yourself from the fire even if
you give half a date in sadaqah. The
link is there, guys. Give in sadaqah
number three. Okay? And your morning and
evening al quran has to be done. You
don't understand how evil some people
are, guys. Do these procedures. Get rid
of it by burning it, okay? And may Allah
protect you, guys, because this here is
very, very dangerous, brothers and
sisters, and it is a reality. A Russian
magician, she said, "What? When anytime
I'm trying to do a spell on the Muslims,
they have an aggregate. They have this
protective dome over them, and I can't
do it." Allah didn't send salah just for
that. That's just a bonus.
Allah deserves our worship. We worship
him alone, yes,
and we ask him for help. So, don't go to
these people, pierce up, this, that. No,
no, no, no, no. Worship Allah cuz that's
the reason why we say
"We worship you alone."
May Allah protect us, inshallah. This is
very, very scary. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. Do not forget
to do all those things and do the
sadaqah, inshallah. Goodbye.